I want to thank you all for coming it's
it's incredibly heartening and exciting
to see so many people turn out to talk
about books and ideas and and in this
case press coverage on a beautiful
Saturday afternoon I think this is one
of the greatest events and in Los
Angeles of the year because it brings
everyone together thank you i will
introduce the panelists and then we'll
have a go at each other for a while and
then we'll open it to questions and your
you will have to go to the mics to ask
your questions because this has been
filmed for c-span so they won't be able
to hear your questions if you don't do
that so we'll start with a mark bowden
I've practiced this all morning mark two
ways you can know and it was 5050 mark
bowden is national correspondent for The
Atlantic magazine and his new book on
the Iran hostage crisis guests of the
Ayatollah will be out this winter from
atlantic monthly press his other books
include Black Hawk Down roadwork Finders
Keepers killing pablo bringing on the
heat and dr. death and he's been a
journalist for many many years
Terry McDermott has been a reporter at
eight newspapers for 25 years the last
seven of them at the los angeles times
in his newspaper jobs he's covered
County Zoning Board state legislators
and the Los Angeles Police Department
with its peculiar culture he's written
on an enormous range of subjects the
financing design and construction of sky
scrapers the search for a rare blood
molecule the California Dream he was
assigned to write about the 911 plot
within days of the attacks on New York
and Washington and that assignment led
to his book which will be out next month
may perfect soldiers Terry McDermott and
chris hedges was a foreign correspondent
for nearly 20 years most of them with
the new york times and is the author of
war is a force that gives us meaning he
was part of the team of the New York
Times reporters who won the 2002
pulitzer prize for the papers coverage
of global terrorism he's covered at
conflicts in Central America where we
first met and in the middle east africa
and the balkans his new book losing
moses on the freeway the Ten
Commandments in America will be out in
June and he's a senior fellow at the
nation Institute chris hedges
so collectively these journalists have
covered a lot of wars in Central America
from Somalia to the so-called war on
terrorism they've immersed themselves in
combat they've stood back and analyze
dictators and al-qaeda warnock warriors
and the question that I would put on the
table is whether the media has advanced
at all in covering war in in this war in
Iraq whether from say Somalia to now
we're doing any better of a job at
presenting the reality of war in getting
at what's really happening during a war
and at reaching the public so that they
are able to have educated opinions about
the war so mark I'll start with you and
ask you if you see any evolution since
Somalia clearly were able to get better
pictures and and faster pictures but do
we have any better or more information
yes we have a lot more information and a
lot better information Mogadishu was is
probably not a good point of comparison
because there were no reporters in
Mogadishu for the battle most of the
news organizations had pulled their
reporters out of Somalia some months
before because it had become so
dangerous and also because it had really
receded as a story Americans weren't
that interested in what was going on
there so when I wrote Black Hawk Down I
mean I covered this is the best way to
cover a war and that as you start after
the battle is over and in you find the
people who were there and you
reconstruct it that way no one shoots at
you while you're working I in the in the
case of Iraq I think that the the
biggest thing was the military's
decision to embed reporters not that
embedded reporters convey the whole
story but i think they convey a very
important part of that story and i think
that all Americans and people all over
the world got a much better feel for and
a much better understanding of what the
United States
was doing whether you liked it or not in
Iraq when they invaded and I think you
know a number of my friends some very
talented very brave journalists have
covered that war and continue to do so
in a way that we haven't seen really
since Vietnam and I think it's a
tremendous benefit to society I mean we
are a democracy we need to make up our
minds about what our military forces are
doing overseas and it's extraordinarily
helpful to have a good feel for what's
actually going on I saw it for instance
in that episode earlier this year where
the NBC reporter was present when a
marine shot and killed a an injured
Iraqi and I think that there was an
appropriate level of outrage over the
fact that that had happened but tempered
with the knowledge of the tremendous
strains that these young men are under
in combat there I think that most people
who saw that both were appalled by the
fact that it happened but also had a
certain measure of understanding and
sympathy for a terrified young soldier
in a very difficult situation making
what apparently was a bad judgment I
think things like that are valuable
extraordinarily valuable and are only
available because of the the opportunity
that journalists have been given to
cover that war and we've also seen you
know the growth of international media
television from Arab states from
European channels who are covering the
war from different perspectives
sometimes very jarring and difficult for
Americans to see but I think extremely
healthy and important so I see an
improvement it's interesting that if you
go back to Somalia you had very few
reporters or photographers very very
little press and yet the impact of the
killing of just a few Americans had was
dramatic on foreign policy basically
forced to pull out by the Clinton
administration and in fact affected
future deployments and the willingness
or not to go into the Balkans right and
here you have hundreds of Americans
dying all the time
and it seems to have very little impact
on public opinion or policy what do you
make of that well I think it had such a
huge impact in Somalia precisely because
that the deaths in the Battle of
Mogadishu occurred if entirely free of
context I think you know most Americans
had no idea that American soldiers were
being sent out on missions in Mogadishu
that were so dangerous and so that the
possibility of a running gun battle over
18 hours where 18 to 19 Americans are
killed and thousands of Somalis are
killed was a complete surprise and so I
think people were shocked I think there
was very little understanding in this
country of what the nature of the
American mission was in Somalia so those
deaths and in particular those
grotesques images of dead American
soldiers being dragged through the
streets of Mogadishu took place as I say
in a vacuum and people reacted with the
very obvious responses why is this
happening and you know why are our
soldiers there let's get them out of
there what could possibly be important
enough in Somalia for American soldiers
to be dying in the case of Iraq clearly
it's a totally different situation and
whether you agree with invading Iraq or
not Americans certainly understood what
was going on and understood what the
stakes were and what the conditions were
like and so the fact that American
soldiers are killed in that conflict
comes in a context that either angers us
or or inspires us or saddens us but
certainly one that we can can comprehend
and of course one of the changes is is
911 we're operating in a post-september
11th World Terry you cover the elusive
war on terror which does not have
traditional battlefronts you can't go
see the war on the ground exactly you
can't go talk to the other side in the
war you have greater secrecy in the
United States less access to public
records or officials to talk on the
subject limited or no access to
knees accused of being connected with
al-qaeda how do you cover this war not
very well it's extraordinarily difficult
and it's difficult in a often not very
interesting way it's mean it's not
difficult in the complexity of it is so
rich and you can really sink into it
it's just basic facts are really hard
fought I spent I'm sure months where I
went backwards I mean I would lose
information information it turn out not
to be true one of the I think this
applies to war coverage generally the
war on terror is I mean it almost not a
war in some ways but you have
extraordinarily imperfect information
and I think although in Iraq we have a
lot more reporters there a lot more
access to information images I don't
think we have a broad understanding of
what's going on I think in this is a
problem for reporter covering anything
but wars are in particular it's it's
everything is messy it's hard to get to
get a feel for the whole the overall
thing it's just you get bits and pieces
and there's the old cliche of you know
the blind man in elephant you don't know
if you're where you are on the elephant
at all and you really don't in a war
generally I think in covering terrorism
in particular I mean for people covering
a real war you can usually get access to
American to the American side of it and
rarely to the other side in in terrorism
you can't get access to either side I
mean it's just dirt and so you have this
real positive information which skews
the information that you do have every
fact is so unusual to be a fact that
it's elevated in a way that it might not
ought to be you'd have an example with
911 just after the events I think within
before the end of the year it was
revealed that two of the hijackers had
been in Malaysia Kuala Lumpur in the
year prior and it had been a meeting
there though they were tailed to this
meeting by American intelligence
operatives I mean American CIA stations
around the world track these guys to the
meeting and then they lost them after
the meeting was over in a flew to LA
that had been didn't pick that part up
but the meeting seemed to take on real
importance but the reason is because the
only meeting we knew about means as it
turns out apparently the meeting was a
little import at all hi myself spent six
months trying to figure out the meeting
you know and it was just too it was a
they met there because if I looked
better if they came the United States
from through Thailand it was completely
unimportant a lot of ways so in
terrorism you're doing that all the time
you don't know you don't even know if
the people are important that you're
trying to find out about you end up
doing things that are probably there
certainly in retrospect really stupid
it's it's it's not a job I'd wish on
anybody many media critics say that in
fact it's not just the limited or lack
of access it's that we as the media have
been too complacent that in this
post-september 11th era that we have
been to accepting of the word of power
that we you know whether it's in the
case of the the lawyer from from oregon
or jose padilla that we we aren't
pushing hard enough and we aren't
challenging or questioning enough is
there anything to that i think generally
there is yeah i don't think that i don't
think we've stayed with the stories long
enough i think that we've kind of gone
and done them and then come home I did
nothing since September 11th except
September 11th coverage and there were
periods i would go months without seeing
all the reporters doing anywhere you
know initially afterward there was a
there were thousands of there are too
many reporters that to allow you to do
your job actually because if a source
would pop up I mean he'd be surrounded
by 30 reporters like a school shooting
but then people went away to a certain
extent I thought they have the story and
they kind of understood it and knew
enough and maybe they did I don't know
but so much of what's reported in the
early going is wrong it factually wrong
and so much else is irrelevant it's like
the kuala lumpur me so you end up with
people having a very skewed idea what
actually happens i don't know about the
two respectful of power it's just it's
more measure the difficulty of finding
information independently I know that
I've interviewed people who've never
been interviewed by anybody else who
were seriously good information about
this and they've never been approached
by the reporters nobody could find them
even know their names then you have the
problem of if you try to track somebody
down what if you do find him I mean did
you really want to I mean that that's
what happened to Danny pearl he got in
the car with somebody he didn't know in
a place he didn't know and everybody's
fun including me one was really stupid
and he was just those mistakes should
have done that two months later I was in
crotch a did the same thing because you
get so desperate for information that
you really do you do things that
ordinarily you would like to thank you
wouldn't Chris in in Gulf War one the
press was all but locked out of the war
arena the military corralled reporters
and tried to keep them away from the
front lines and we tried to do this
differently in in the three-week Iraq
war we the military tried to do it
differently in that they embedded
reporters the media tried to do it
differently in that we stayed in Baghdad
this time and Kurdistan and then we
tried to come in unilaterally behind
behind the military I would ask you if
that was any more productive in the
covering of of that war well i looked at
i covered the Persian Gulf or I was not
in a pool system
was you know one of the unilateral 'he's
a new word we invented for our job and i
think in fact that the first persian
gulf war was essentially the the staging
ground or the that we were seeing the
beginnings of press control that were
perfected in this war remember we had a
we had a hundred and sixty pool
reporters in the persian gulf war who
are essentially hostages of the US
military they couldn't go they didn't
have their own vehicles they were
dependent on the military for
transportation for foods for security
and they saw what the military wanted
them to see and they by and large did
not see what the military did not want
them to see I think the Pentagon looked
very closely at that experience and this
evolved into the embedding programme
where instead of 160 we had 600
reporters who were embedded like the
pool reporters in the Persian Gulf War
again they were completely hostage to
the military and I think that in fact
the advances in technology the ability
to transmit live images decreased the
effectiveness of the reporting in this
sense instead of actually going out and
reporting a story we now got live images
which were a tiny corner of a
battlefield and reporters assume the
role of sports commentators where they
would be crouching behind a berm saying
and now I see a half-track going across
the same oh look there's an exploit and
it's it says it's the same thing
Football announcers do and I think that
it created an illusion that somehow we
were getting more information in fact I
think we were getting less they're
virtually were no independent reporters
in this war unlike in the Persian Gulf
where where I and a few others broke
free of the pool system and that's not
the fault of the reporters and the
photographers it's just that it was too
dangerous
and let's be very clear that the
reporters in Baghdad were under the same
you know as severe constraints I mean
they were controlled by the Iraqi
Ministry of information so that all of
the images and all of the information
from the war came from the either the
lens provided by the US military or the
lens provided by the Iraqi dictatorship
and I think in fact the outside world
had and still has almost no knowledge of
what's going on in Iraq if you you know
anybody who's been with armed units
especially American armed units that
have access to massive amounts of
firepower the ability to call in
airstrikes the ability to call in heavy
artillery knows very well that the
moment they cross from Kuwait they
blasted their way through Baghdad and if
there was a mud-walled village three
kilometers away where somebody thought
that they saw somebody with something in
a matter of minutes that village did not
exist and we blew our way into Baghdad
then proceeded in Baghdad to use
incredibly heavy weapons including tow
anti-tank missiles 50 caliber machine
guns etc etc in urban areas and you know
I think one of the things when Marjorie
and I covered the war in El Salvador you
we learned very quickly that the best
recruiting weapon the FMLN rebels had in
el salvador were the death squads who
were when i got to el salvador 1983
killing between 800 and thousand people
a month and i think what we did in
essence has become a recruiting weapon
for the insurgency remember we don't
know but but best estimates are hundred
thousand iraqis have been killed and now
the situation is so volatile that we
don't have any voices at all I think we
know almost nothing I think we knew I
think in fact they perfected a system
and its y vice president cheney after
the war will laud the embedding system
is a bit success that should tip you off
right there that perhaps we didn't do
our job so let me let me go beyond the
three week award oust saddam hussein at
the end of that war the international
media attempted to do what we tried to
do in Central America and the Balkans
which is to dig in and to start covering
it
from the ground from all sides that
worked for a little while I mean you
actually had reporters going out looking
for insurgents until it became clear
that anybody who looked like a westerner
was a potential target for the
insurgents and so suddenly it became
impossible to cover the war from the
ground so and that was the best the only
moment of real reporting and the LA
Times did some very good work and I
think so did the New York Times where
they actually went into villages you
know the I think you have to be in a war
zone to understand the awesome power of
this weaponry and I remember a story in
The New York Times where you know
there's been a couple flashes from a
Kalashnikov off or something and they
just obliterated the village and when
the reporter went in I can remember
there was burns or someone else they
said oh well we don't we don't really
know because we're still trying to put
the body parts back together and I think
that there was a brief window which you
mentioned and again that's not the fault
of the reporters in the photographer's
which is too dangerous I mean now your
choice is either your embedded or you're
sitting in a press briefing in the Green
Zone that's basically it if you can get
to the Green Zone and let's be very
clear about the embedded process there
are very clear rules about that you know
many many Iraqis are killed at
checkpoints we saw the incident with the
Italian intelligence officer and the
freed Italian hostage but this is
something that's happening to Iraqis
every single day and but if embedded
reporters start reporting on this
they're not going to be embedded very
long there are very clear rules about
what you can say and what you can and I
think the lie of war having spent 20
years of my life covering war is almost
always the lie of omission and I think
that's the lie that were that we're
suffering from now and I think we
understand almost nothing about what's
happening in Iraq mark what what is the
stomach for the truth right now I mean
if you think about the images out of
Somalia we don't really have that were
the images out of Vietnam the iconic
images of war do we don't really have
those images now
while we can't get a lot of them through
in beds and well let me say first I want
to defend the embedding programme
because I think Chris over States this
point the embedding I think was a
tremendous success and I would be the
first to agree that there no one has
figured out a way to cover a war as
completely as it needs to be covered
giving you both the details on the
ground and the overview while it's
happening I doubt that that's ever going
to happen but there's no question that
we got a lot more out of the embedded
reporting of that war than the images
that appeared on television initially
during the middle of firefights where
you had reporters crouched like sports
commentators saying oh look they just
fired a horrid so Howard Howard served
from over there there have been any
number of reporters who've come back and
written extremely good books and
magazine articles analyzing you know
their experience writing very candidly
about the soldiers they were with
writing books that in many cases I'm
sure the military is not real thrilled
to see in print some of the reporters
and friends of mine from the LA Times
from the New York Times from newspapers
all over this country have done
extremely good very independent work
even though they were embedded in a
military unit and I think that you know
you are going to continue to see for a
long time a higher level of
sophistication in writing about this war
coming from people who had the
experience of being on the ground during
the fighting so I think that it it is
unquestionably in my mind an improvement
over the way say for instance the
Persian Gulf War was covered which as I
understand it consisted of the very few
brave people like Chris and my friend of
Michael Kelly were actually driving
around trying to do their own reporting
and the vast majority of reporters who
were being who were covering the war
from a conference room somewhere and
we're in a different country so we do I
think reporters did get a lot closer to
this war so I'm sorry they know I would
agree with that in fact i think that the
embed provides pieces of a mosaic and
there have been a number of stories like
the one you mentioned that actually came
Matt of embeds what you know i can think
of Bill Brannigan of the post during
during the three-week war writing a
story about killing civilians at
checkpoints and David's Aquino for the
LA Times writing about whether was the
finding of the money or the going into
the palaces or any number of things were
actually how how very difficult and
bloody it was to take Baghdad but but I
still wonder if the media in general has
the state the same stomach it had for
publishing the kind of the brutal and
and death brutality and death of the war
and worried but I think unquestionably
it does I mean it may not be the
mainstream media that publishes it but
we live in a world now with the internet
of international television crews I was
in Europe when Iraq was invaded so most
of the TV coverage that I watched was
from European stations and they would
show things on TV in Europe that they
wouldn't show in the United States and
the truth is that I mean the some of the
images that we've seen from this war are
some of the most horrific that I've ever
seen in my lifetime people being
beheaded and you know shot down it's
just it's grotesque if you choose to
look at those images you can go find
them I think that's one of the features
of modern times so yes I think that it's
all out there for anybody who wants to
take it in we don't but the point is
we're waging the war and we don't see it
the rest of the world may see it but we
don't but you but you can see it Bobby
for instance remember when they George
Bush and Condoleezza Rice wanted to
prevent the networks from broadcasting
Osama bin Laden's statements on TV and
this was hilarious because I was in
Michigan where you know you can get al
Jazeera from a satellite hookup and you
can watch any of the stuff that you and
I was with an Iraqi family who they were
watching al-jazeera on TV in Detroit I
mean it's the idea that somehow even if
they wanted to control access to
information in this country not in this
day and age
is you can't do it if you make the
effort on the internet and other places
yes you can go find alternative sources
of information but the mainstream media
in this country prevents the presents a
very skewed image of the war and that
kind of self-censorship is something
that's always done in war and it's not
necessarily political it's just done for
what's palatable nobody ever really sees
a war finally I think until they're in a
war that the images that come out are
always so sanitized and and in terms of
the embedding programme yes while there
were few exceptions to the rule in some
of the cases that you cited I think you
have to look at the overall weight and
also remember that most Americans or a
very large percentage of Americans get
their information through images and and
the print journalists have I think less
and less impact and especially in the
age of sort of live television
broadcasts and while there have been
some good books Generation Kill and some
others that have come out again and that
happens after every war it comes out
after the war I think we have to look
when we talk about reporting newps
what's coming out during the conflict I
would ask then it's not only that I mean
we can't talk about covering this war by
talking about the human bed process
because that was the three weeks yeah we
still know everybody's to know but but
it's is such a small part of what the
war is but not now I mean this only way
people can get out is to embed that's
the only way you can get out in Iraq now
we're getting out a little bit more but
i guess i would ask what's the
alternative is it better not to embed or
not to cover the war or do you keep
pushing the boundaries by embedding by
staying in baghdad and going out when
you can go out i mean reporters in
Baghdad test the violence like you know
we test the weather you know is it okay
it's important to that they're not hold
up in Baghdad because they are too timid
to step outside the American you know
American military's control of
information it's because it's dangerous
no no it's not and journalists have
become targets and ya know it's
in this case it's not the fault of the
reporters of photographers but but the
you know look I've been with units in
combat and there's a natural kind of
tendency one that I myself have fell to
protect the people who are protecting
you you build a kind of bond with the
unit and if you cover a conflict of
course you need people who are embedded
you can't cover a conflict otherwise but
when all of your information in essence
comes from embedded reporters what
you're doing is essentially looking at a
conflict through the prism of the
occupiers and not just the occupiers but
the armed professional killers of the
occupiers and that gives such a skewed
vision of what's going on in Iraq the
only way to cover a conflict is to have
people who speak Arabic who understand
the culture who can which you I
understand that you can't do it now but
I think we have to be very clear that we
are getting an extremely distorted
vision of what's going on I mean when
Marjorie and I covered the war in El
Salvador we spend you know three days
with the Salvadoran army and then we
turn around and go out with the fmln and
and of course our own nation was not
involved in the conflict and this is an
important distinction I think that when
your own country is involved there
become all sorts of pressures on you to
sort of get with the team but I think
that that the coverage out of a place
like El Salvador was much more balanced
because of that because of that kind of
access and we just have to be clear I'm
not blaming it on the reporters and
photographers because we saw in that
window at the end of the invasion when
people could travel very good reporting
and that window is closed but we have to
be clear that we don't understand what's
going on in Iraq I think that we should
open it to questions because we could go
on talking forever please keep your keep
it to questions and not comments if you
would and please keep it short because I
imagine there'll be a lot of people who
want to ask questions
like to know we we used to cover the
foreign desk of newspapers used to cover
foreign countries they would have
reporters there living there knowing the
culture Chris just mentioned a little
bit about that that you knew that
language you know the people over there
and you had your sources and you knew
the government we don't do that anymore
we just we do a flyby and we get the
reports and you have one or two contacts
and we come back well I would say that
you are actually conjuring up a idyllic
vision of a world that never existed in
journalism there were I think it's true
there was a heyday of newspapers where
we probably had five or six American
newspapers who maintained foreign
bureaus around the world now it's down
to what Marjorie maybe three or four so
I mean that and the networks have really
cut back but I would say by the same
token you know the growth of
international media the access to
international publications on the
internet the access to international
television and radio through satellites
has probably given us all in this day
and age an opportunity to learn more
about any conflict than anybody ever had
an opportunity to in the past I would
also add that I think that is
unfortunately the case in Iraq for all
of the reasons that we've said but that
isn't the case in the rest of the world
I mean we the Los Angeles Times has
about 25 correspondence all over the
world most of them speak the language
live in the country talk to real people
in real time so Iraq is a problem but
it's not representative of how we cover
the world yeah although it is true that
the network's don't do it anymore I mean
when we when we were in Central America
every Network had a bureau they had
reporters they went out they reported a
story they produced it you know they
like the bangbang too much it was three
and a half minutes but they were doing
journalism that's gone now when we were
young things were bad
nobody but I think that anything again I
think it goes back to television and you
know I think if you just look at
people's perceptions in the United
States of the war in Iraq you see how
pernicious that corrosion within the
broadcast media has been I think you
still have great newspapers like the LA
Times and The Washington Post New York
Times yes but I think in the electronic
media there's been a terrible terrible
erosion of real journalistic standards
and values Oh miss MacDermott I wanted
to thank you for you x anarkali had
about the motivation for al-qaeda when
we were attacked on 911 how was the
support for Israel and James Bamford can
face that in his pretext for war book
and was also addressed on page 147 of
the 911 Commission report my question is
why aren't we addressing that in all
these intelligence reforms and thus war
on terror we're spending billions of
dollars when if you remember George
Washington's farewell address as
president he said avoid the passionate
attachment for a foreign country and
here we are supporting Israel to the
extent that we are and we're being
attacked because of it and again I
learned this from your article my
question is how much longer we're going
to go on basically playing a shell game
of say we're going to pay all these
billions of dollars out to fight the war
and terror and go to war in Iraq which
is actually increased our Tara risk as
we spend 300 billion dollars why aren't
we going to cut to the chase that the
terror problem is the result of
supporting Israel's to pressure the
positive answer the question well first
of all I'm not capable of answering the
question I I'm not the American
government I don't make those policies
yeah um apartamento yeah I mean I think
that I mean I hate to say it but he has
something of a point in that the
political motivations of al Qaeda have
been less emphasized then they probably
ought to have been or than we were aware
existed I think and a lot of the
motivation for bin Laden and his people
is political and not really
and we tended to demonize them as
religious fanatics I mean they might
well have been religious fanatics but
that was not their sole motivation I
mean that there's a lot of things Duan
to get somebody in position but are
willing to commit suicide and kill
thousands of people and it isn't always
just a single cause and it's true Middle
East politics play a role in that they
motivated the guide the mastermind of
the 911 plot Pakistani name Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed it was motivated
principally by admit us middies policy
he says and there's no reason to doubt
that the one of the lead hijackers
Mohamed Atta was motivated principally
by politics and not religion so there's
a point and I and I don't know where we
lost it but we did that which doesn't
say that the policy is good or bad I
mean what I don't know what America's
policy at least ought to be and I'm not
equipped to answer it and wouldn't if I
was but but i mean i would i would not
have a job to go back to tonight but but
it plays a large role look I mean it I'm
not a press pass sure as you know I'm a
former journalist and the truth is you
know I talked to people all over this
country about it and there's pretty much
universal agreement but the coverage of
the war in Iraq is pretty terrible and I
would tend to agree with you Chris but
it's not the recorders fault but my
question is where is the muscle of the
New York Times in the LA Times why
aren't they taking on the government and
saying look you're not letting us do our
job why isn't there why isn't the news
media fighting for for their place the
way they did in Vietnam
well I you know I cannot be a spokesman
for the new york times but i think part
of the problem is that we play by rules
rules where we try and give everyone a
voice where there's an attempt to be
objective and i think that we're dealing
with a government that doesn't play by
rules and i think that the problem is
it's you know reminds me of the you know
the movie of fish called wanda and kevin
kline and michael caine are squaring off
and and Michael Caine has the pistol and
Kevin client says fight like a real man
and Michael Caine drops the pistol and
says yes I used a box for oxford and
kevin kline picks up the pistol and said
well i used to kill for the CIA I think
we're all boxing for Oxford I think
that's the problem and I think that you
know you know the the very clear lies
that were told to justify this war the
way this administration played the press
like a violin the fact that there were
no dissenting voices even though that
there were large numbers of people in
the intelligence community in the
Pentagon among inspection teams in Iraq
i covered i covered the Gulf War and
then I was in the Middle East for the
inspection teams that destroyed far more
weaponry including biological and
chemical weapons than were ever
destroyed by the coalition forces and I
think all you had to do was pick up
James you know Defense analysis to
realize how absolutely impotent the
Iraqi military was but you know there
was I think 911 contributed to it but
yes I think we failed terribly and I
think with it in many ways the press is
been knocked off balance by an
administration that has very little
regard for I think what we do and
certainly no regard for telling the
truth
American public what it let me follow
that up with a question I think the
press admits widely what a what a lousy
job we did in the run-up to the war in
in pursuing the whole question of
weapons of mass destruction the
justification for going to war after the
war I think the press was fairly good at
going at this question and and finding
out more and coming to the conclusion
that there were no weapons but then it
seemed that the public didn't care why
well i think you know we have to be
frank that a large segment of this
public was complicitous in this war you
know the i was i had written this book
wars a force that gives us meaning which
is sort of a diatribe against war and
what it does to culture and individuals
and because i had spent seven years in
the middle east in the build-up to the
war the iraqi issue came up and it
incited very fierce passions very angry
passions i mean even threats on the
phone and this kind of stuff and i think
that there was i mean if you looked at
broadcast media especially outlets like
Fox it became a celebration of our own
power or certainly the power of our
military the power of our weaponry you
know they would always bring in retired
military people that talk about what
cruise missiles could do and for those
of us who had been in conflicts there
was a kind of very it was almost
pornographic I mean it was very
frightening there was never any even
discussion about what was happening on
the other end the pools of blood the
cries of the wounded and the dying and
you know it it was a very perverse view
of what war was completely skewed and
again I you know I think that while the
standards were kept in the serious
newspapers those standards were were
because of the corrosion of broadcast
media irrelevant and it became self
exultation with
is essentially what nationalism is and
and so that self exaltation that sense
of empowerment informed a large part of
the public and I think that one has to
be very clear about that and I think
that when you wonder why I think because
it's not just the administration that's
guilty in some ways we're all guilty one
of you mentioned the idea that Americans
don't follow certain news so then they
are not followed by their media
shouldn't the media really tell us the
truth of what is happening and any of
you can tell us what really happened in
Fallujah after the election in Iraq you
know I can say that I've been a
journalist my whole life and I've never
done anything but try to tell the truth
in what i write about and what I learned
whether I know everything that I would
like to know whether it's possible for
me to find out information obviously the
answer is you can't always know
everything you'd like to know but and
I'm not alone I mean I've worked a long
career in newspapers in magazine writing
writing books I have a wide circle of
acquaintance ship in this profession and
it's actually very few people I've run
across over the course of my career who
are trying to do anything other than
learn and understand and write the truth
I actually think that one of the more
alarming trends in American journalism
is the are things like Fox TV the the
tendency of television networks
magazines newspapers to adopt a
political slant on their coverage which
is very typical of journalism in Europe
and other parts of the world I think one
of the most valuable things about the
American tradition of journalism has
been maintaining a more even-handed
objective standard in reporting
information and I see an erosion of that
certainly as for Fallujah I only know
you know what I've read and frankly what
I've read in American publications and
seen on TV is that the United States
fairly destroyed Fallujah
you know 95 what a case of one of the
military men there said it was you know
one of the classic cases that we had to
destroy the village in order to save it
and you know so I mean I don't
understand in all honesty this
allegation that we Americans are being
deprived of information about what's
going on in this war I saw a lot of
reporting about collateral damage and
and and civilians being killed in Iraq
not just in American publications but
all over the world I didn't see it on
Fox I'll be the first to agree that it
was obscene you know the way Fox covered
this war but thankfully their only one
of a you know fairly large number of
cable news outlets in this country you
know and and so if I know that Fallujah
was destroyed over the course of you
know what happened after that election
and I think most Americans know that
that's the case you don't think so I
mean that's Fallujah was well let me
tell you now Fallujah was destroyed and
it hasn't been the same sense of it and
maybe it will come back to life at a
certain point but Fallujah is sorry well
it's going to say that the problem isn't
a conspiracy among journalists I mean
you could sis journals couldn't conspire
to go to launch I
that the problem is that the difficulty
is daunting to get to know what the
truth is is the problem it's hard work
yeah and in any profession there are
people who work very hard and put
themselves at risk in order to get
information and they are a minority well
but the problem is that we now have an
army of pseudo journalist who are posing
as journalists yeah that's always been
the case I mean it's almost as though
you're positing some point in the past
where there were armies and perfect
journalists that were never armies a
perfect journalist but I you know over
the course of my career watched the
erosion in the broadcast media it's very
real I can tell you I mean it that's not
you know the broad CBS especially the
network's it was very different 20 years
ago it was they were much better they
were still reporting they don't do it
anymore in addition to that I would add
that Fallujah is an example of what we
described before which is that even if
you couldn't get the truth by
accompanying American military we can't
just run up there afterwards and find
out what happened because it's too risky
because we as Westerners are perceived
as or we believe we're perceived as the
enemy so it's not like we can run up and
corner some insurgents and get the other
side of the store there is a solution to
the erosion of quality of television
journalism and that is to read
newspapers it seems like a lot of like
the press seems to be rushing to the
next big story and they're leaving a lot
of big stories behind like the sales
seems to be so much left over from 9-11
that we still don't know about and I'm
getting worried that you know Massari
one of the the terrorists that he just
admitted his to being complicit I'm
getting worried that he's going to be
put to death no one's gonna get a chance
to interview this guy is that
possibility and also what happened to
the money that was supposedly profited
from the airlines to put options that
was a story i read about from the
american airlines that there were
supposedly a lot of money that was a
maid
fitted from the put options on american
airlines united airlines dropping
drastically in in their stocks that was
this is story that i saw one national
news and then they totally dropped it
and I'd never heard anything I would
couldn't find anything on the internet
about it what wasn't true so I yeah well
I it was reported after the fact but all
the sorts of questions come from again
this notion that we know a lot more than
what then we're letting on and in fact
we may be know a lot less than we're
letting on much of the time well also
I've been what part of the question was
why you know the fact that our media our
press moves from story to story in it in
it and it's always been the case I mean
a journalism in this country for the
most part is especially nowadays with so
many TV channels it's miles wide and
about an inch deep and I mean I wrote
about the Battle of Mogadishu which I
think was probably the most significant
combat that a lot of American soldiers
have been involved in in a generation
and I worked on that story for three or
four years and there wasn't a soul
working on that except me and after a
Black Hawk Down came out a lot of people
said well how come we didn't know you
know about what happened there well in
fact there was a lot of reporting about
it for about two weeks and then
everybody moved on to that to the
revolution in Russia and you know to the
next big breaking story but I think it's
always been the case and I'm thankful
for my own career sake that that most
journalists don't stay on a story for
three or four years and really dig into
it and try to really understand it and
it isn't just their fault it's that
their news organizations are rare that
financed you know that kind of work who
will pay a salary to a reporter and as
benefits so that he can spend three or
four years really digging into a story
and in my experience you need to spend
that length of time particularly when
you're reporting from a foreign country
where you don't understand even some of
the basics about what's going on you
need to put in that kind of investment
in order to begin to understand what
happened for most foreign correspondents
to denigrate these fine people on the
panel yes spending two or three days on
stories a long time most of them are
covering seven or eight countries are
cotton you know cotton we have two
people covering Africa I think you know
I mean we have three now but in problem
solved right yeah but you know and as
Marge that we have the other times as 25
people and that's I mean there's only
three for four or five papers that have
your license you have that we try to
keep them from going on vacation hi I'm
a USC journalism student and my goal is
to become a war correspondent I'm also
specializing in human rights abroad and
so all this talk about the New
Journalism you know the bad journalists
that are coming into the profession I'm
a clean slate so give me advice I just
want to know what was your first
experience with war reporting what have
you learned that you wish you knew then
and you know what can I do to become
what you hope is good a good journalist
who I never wanted to be a work where
Spanish you know I get petrified and
can't stand it when I'm in danger yeah
unfortunately Wars keep breaking out
everywhere I think it's not a lofty goal
I think that what's a lofty goal is to
be a good foreign correspondent and you
know to try to get to the truth of
whatever's going on wherever you are and
to you know try to explain to readers in
this case to Americans why it is
important to understand the rest of the
world and why to engage as opposed to
withdrawing why don't you talk about how
you got well I I never went to
journalism school I went to seminary and
same thing and I went to Latin America
sent Latin America is a freelance
reporter in the early 80s at the time of
the military dictatorships because I
thought it was as close as my generation
was going to come to fighting fascism I
really didn't have any interest in
building a career in journalism I wanted
to give a voice to people who are living
under the boot of these dictatorships my
hero was Orwell remains or well for his
honesty his ability to criticize all
sides of a movement and I think that
those are I don't have a problem with
those motivations I don't think that
precludes you from telling the truth I
think that you know it's very hard to
sit in the midst of a war and I covered
the war in Bosnia and stand over you
know bodies of people who have been
butchered and not feel anything you
can't ask us not to feel anything I
would agree with Marjorie you know being
a war correspondent is a personality
type and probably not a really healthy
one so
you know and it doesn't really matter
what we tell you if you're bent in that
direction you will go I can spend an
hour giving you reasons not to go and
you'll go anyway that's was certainly my
case but I think that that you know that
too much work you know I I think
sometimes and I think this was the
problem with the coverage of the
build-up to the war is that yes we have
to be objective yes we have to be fair
but and I think you know the the editor
of the New York Times and a speech I
some give also raised a very important
issue that it's not just a matter of
being objective and fair but we have a
contract with the reader or the viewer
and that is to tell the truth and that
objectivity and neutrality without that
deep passion to tell the truth is farce
and I think that a passion to tell the
truth means that you embrace values and
that you you do take a moral stance it's
why when the Serbs would cut the roads
into Kosovo in villages where they had
killed people we would put our satellite
phones in our backpack and walk and you
know it didn't mean the Serbs weren't
going to go in and kill people in
another village you know you you have to
accept often your insignificance in the
midst of a war or your minimal
significance but it becomes a battle of
light to shine light in areas of deep
darkness and and i think that there's
nothing wrong with embracing a moral
code and I think sometimes in this
sanitized world of American journalism
or frightened to do that I want to talk
about why you do it
and I want to respond to your question
that you asked for advice and I would
say one piece of advice I would give you
is don't pretend to know more than you
know and to realize how little you know
and realize how much power something new
has an image a story something true that
people hadn't known before has
tremendous power in the world and it's
amazing how much gets said and written
and reported that doesn't tell you
anything new so I mean if you want to be
a foreign correspondent and a war
reporter it if you get the opportunity
to do that you know you'll have a chance
to go places that most Americans don't
go you won't know anything you ought to
know that you don't know anything that's
important and pay attention and ask
questions and try not to make up your
mind about what you're going to discover
before you discover it and tell the
truth you know and and always be working
on the most ambitious thing you've ever
done that way you'll continue to grow
why do I do it I do it for the money
myself that was a roofer I kept falling
off seem like it's all safe yeah yeah
you don't get up don't get up that high
you know I do it because I'm interested
in in learning I mean it's it so you're
being it's a paid tutorial for your life
you run around the world and learn stuff
and it's great joy in that in that sense
and it's a chance to understand how
people work and to even nystrom three
years studying the nine eleven hijackers
and even that has been great joy in
trying to understand how those guys got
there what what kind of people what kind
of world produces people who do that and
that's been it's heartening for me to be
able to go out and come back with an
image of that the advice I would give
those is much like march i think be
careful what you believe
you have to be able to almost throw away
everything in your head tomorrow if it
doesn't fit you have to be ready to be
yet that you're you have to hypothesis
you have to have a theory to walk out
the door in the morning but you have to
be willing to discard it change it to
fit and you will it to the facts I think
we have time for one more question with
regards to covering the war and the kind
of the new technology and video cameras
with that soldiers have access to have
seen a lot of home videos and whatnot I
was curious what insights you might guys
might have and towards how that line can
blur for the soldier as a journalist and
or any kind of anecdotes through
experience or what not well it makes it
a lot harder to cover things up because
some of the most significant stories
that have emerged from Iraq have come
from soldiers who took pictures and who
put them on the internet and i think
that's it going to be increasingly the
case not just because individuals have
the capability now with the internet of
broadcasting and posting information but
because the as i keep saying the growth
of international media I mean you know
we are so used to in this country the
United States entertainment industry and
news industry dominating information in
the world and we are fast approaching
the end of that era that we are entering
an era where you know the international
sources of information are going to be
commonplace they already are to an
extent and you know our view of the
world will just become one voice among
many so okay thank you very much
appreciate your coming